you know I usually don't ask a question
that's very simple which is how did you
get this part but I think in the case of
a actress like you and a part like this
where it's playing young Emily Dickinson
a part that will then be played by
Grammy Emmy and Tony winners Cynthia
Nixon I would imagine a lot of young
actors really wanted this how did you go
about testing for it reading for it yeah
um well you're absolutely right it was
sort of a dream audition to even just go
in for something to potentially play
Emily Dickinson was just beyond my scope
of understanding but I went in and
parents obviously comes from England and
so he had picked the standard Hotel on
the Sunset Strip as the audition plays
which I thought was a very bizarre place
to be auditioning for Emily Dickinson
but you know I go and I was very very
nervous and I walked into the lobby and
I immediately beeline for the lobby
restroom because I was like I need to
kind of just need to like chill out be a
little you know calm before I go into
this audition and I'm waiting in line
and just this man kind of British man's
like pushing in front of me and I was
like excuse me sir I don't know what
they do in your country but in this
country we wait for ladies to use the
restroom and then I walked into the
bathroom oh no and I like grouped myself
and I fixed myself and I walk out and I
sign in and the door opens and it's
Terrence and he was the man that I had
just given lip to 30 seconds before and
I was just my face turned the color of
the lovely curtains behind me I'm pretty
sure and I just had to recite Emily
Dickinson poems for the audition
basically and also do one of the scenes
that Cynthia gets one of the meet where
she she hits the the plate and she's
like it's clean it's dirty no longer I
love that but um but I had to launch
into that just so humiliated
but I guess I did a good enough job
because parents I think in a way me
being like that spoke to him a little
bit as to Emily because she was quite
you know she had a little bit of a
sense of snark about her so I think in a
weird way being rude to the director
finally worked out one thing that struck
me in some of the early scenes I'm
trying to member exactly how this comes
through I think it was in an opera when
you're watching the Opera and then also
when we learned about Emily first being
interested in poetry there are men who
just have no regard for the fact that
women should be doing these things can
actually do these things what was that
like to learn about those kind of
attitudes that I'm sure we're fairly
pervasive in this time period yeah I
mean I think this movie is a deep
exploration into that I mean so much of
Emily's you know how she carried herself
to her world or alternatively how she
kind of stepped away from the world is
because of that in large part I think
you know women were definitely not
considered to be equals in outside of
the home you know and yeah I mean it was
fun it was fun to be able to play a
woman who is just not of her time and be
able to have the the wealth of
vocabulary that those people had to you
know effectively you know shoot little
Barb's of people you know just using
their intelligence to really rise above
these men or women who had thoughts that
women shouldn't be you know outside of
the house and outside of being docile or
quiet so that yeah that was just that
was just really fun for me I mean yeah I
just got to roll my eyes at men and they
say snarky things but like as if I was
Emily it was very fun what if anything
were you and Terrance and Cynthia able
to do to help with the fact that this is
a tandem performance I don't know if you
shot before she did were you able to
watch her talk to her see any of her
footage how did that work yeah I was you
know was a really tight schedule it was
a truly independent film so there wasn't
the luxury of time I actually shot all
of my stuff footage before Cynthia
arrived so we didn't have a lot of
overlapping time unfortunately but I
will talk to it all before you started
filming yeah we chatted
few times um she's a very busy lady so
she was coming from I think one Broadway
show or something like that um so she
she kind of landed and we had a couple
days overlap actually the day that
overlapped was the where it goes from me
to her in the photo I mean isn't that so
cool that was a very cool technical day
but anyway so that was the day we sort
of met in that in that moment which is
kind of cool actually
yeah it was very much so and I still had
a few days left and and she was very
gracious and we would you know we would
chat but also Terrence was our
through-line and parents was sort of our
sounding board and it didn't even
necessary I mean I love to talk to
people if I'm portraying them as a
younger version of them or what have you
or if we're sharing a character in any
way and I noticed that Cynthia feels the
same way but given the time constraints
we really relied on parents and he
obviously knows this world back and
forth and and was able to point us in
the right direction
well I congratulate you I hope you all
enjoyed the film Emma Belle matt is done